[Musique]
faut pas que ce soit ouf le jingle mais
bon vous êtes bon en tout cas vous êtes
bon vous allez revenir demain j'aime
bien la typo
c'est pas mal vous voulez le refaire
[Musique]
merci
en tout cas merci merci
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il devrait te suivre toute
la journée
autant de CO2 qu'une voiture chaque jour
mais certaines banques éthiques existent
et qui investissent dans des secteurs
nettement moins polluants
de 5000 euros produit 2,6 tonnes de CO2
ce qui équivalent l'utilisation
quotidienne d'une voiture 25000 €, c'est
11 tonnes de CO2 par an 250 millions
d'euros c'est autant que l'empreinte
carbone individu sur une année
ça veut dire qu'on peut demander à sa
banque dans quoi elle investit pour être
sûr exactement
certaines formes d'épargne servent à
financer des industries polluantes
charbon pétrole gaz
et comment tu sais ce qu'on fait avec
ton épargne il faut que tu demandes
comment tu peux culpabiliser
pour la planète on peut plus déplacer on
peut plus utiliser d'électricité on peut
plus d'argent enfin c'est quoi le but
préféré investir dans une économie qui
n'est pas polluante plutôt que
son argent c'est pour ça que tu as des
banques qui proposent des déplacements
vous croyez que vous croyez absolument
attention je vais ça va être très
excellent ce que je vais faire n'importe
quoi ils vont faire de la merde plus
5000 + 5000 n'importe quoi arrêtez
d'être là-dedans
moi je veux bien être écolo mais vous
devenez tous fous là c'est fondamental
les Français les Français et parlent en
moyenne ce qu'ils peuvent ceux qui ont
des difficultés 16 % de leurs revenus
donc il y a beaucoup de revenus qui sont
épargnés et tu peux très bien demander à
ta banque bien sûr moi je mets l'argent
à la banque sous réserve que vous le
placiez dans telle ou tel industrie
une banque qui t'a prêté de l'argent sur
20 ans pour une maison tu crois que tu
allais avoir par contre c'est pas pareil
de changer et de mettre ton épargne
ailleurs de la banque elle va bien voir
ta foutu ton épargne ailleurs
moi je suis écolo et que ça va être
forcément écolo arrêtez de croire ça
arrêtez de croire ça oui c'est
aujourd'hui des des supers gestionnaires
de patrimoine qui peuvent gestionnaires
qui peuvent prendre vos épargnes que
vous avez en trop à la banque au lieu de
laisser à la banque et du coup ils vont
vraiment le placer sur des fonds
d'investissement écologique